[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
SARAH HEWETT:
Today, we are going
to talk about the second
part of the catalase lab.
So, in the first
part of the catalase,
we had catalase and
hydrogen peroxide.
And we were measuring the
rate of the decomposition
of hydrogen peroxide
as catalyzed
by the catalase enzyme.
And we were doing
that by measuring
the pressure of oxygen.
And, for the people
who are currently
doing the catalase lab,
you've already done part one.
And, for everybody
else, you'll get
to experience that coming
up in the next lab or two.
And then, in part two
of the catalase lab,
we are going to
look at quantifying
the amount of catalase
that we have in a sample
and then looking at the
iron centers in the catalase
and trying to quantify
those as well.
So we are going to go
back to the beginning
and talk a little bit more about
proteins and protein structure.
So, if you have taken
a biology course
at any point in your life, then
this will probably be review.
But, just so that we're
all on the same page,
we want to go back and say that
the building blocks of proteins
are amino acids.
And this is the general
structure of an amino acid.
And, if you change
this R group here
to any one of these R
groups over in this table,
then you can get all of
the different amino acids
that are naturally
produced in nature.
And there are 20 amino
acids that occur in nature.
And they vary by these R groups.
And, depending on
the R group, there
are different classes of
amino acids that you can have.
So there are the
nonpolar ones where
you have an alkyl or
an aromatic side chain.
You can have polar
side groups where
you have a hydroxyl group or
a thiol or some amine groups.
And then you can have
acidic or basic groups
that are electrically charged.
So, depending on the
pH of the solution,
they'll either be
protonated or not.
And then you can have
positive and negative charges.
And all of those contribute
to the protein structure
and the properties of the
protein, what it can do.
And just a review
of terminology,
so proteins are made of
chains of amino acids.
A peptide is two or more
amino acids stuck together.
A polypeptide is when you get
10 or more amino acids stuck
together.
And then, if you
have beyond that,
once it gets to longer and
longer chains of amino acids
and they start
folding up and having
specific functions, that's
when it becomes a protein.
So, if you hear
those terms, that's
what we're talking about.
So the first-- the
most basic structure
that you can have in a protein
is the primary structure.
And that is just the
sequence of amino acids.
So you have this long
chain of amino acids.
You stick them together.
And that is the
primary structure.
So, if this is our little
peptide chain here,
we have alanine, threonine,
tyrosine, and valine.
And those are from
these side groups is how
you know what amino acid it is.
And then the bond in
between the amino acids here
where your carbonyl group
of one amino acid bonds
to the amine group of
another amino acid, that
is your peptide bond.
And so you can get
chains of these,
and the primary structure
again is just the list
of amino acids in a line.
That's about as
simple as it gets.
The secondary structure is
how the amino acids interact
with one another to
form 3D structures
within the polypeptide chain.
So, if you have two
chains of amino acids
or if you have one that's
folded onto itself,
it can form hydrogen bonds
between these oxygens
of the carbonyls and
the hydrogens that
are attached to the nitrogens
in the protein backbone.
And you can get
these beta sheets
that are kind of pleated if
you look at them in actual 3D
space.
And you can have one
long chain that bonds
to itself in the similar fashion
with the hydrogen bonding.
And you can get alpha helices.
And it creates a helical shape
within the protein backbone.
And these are the main types
of secondary structures
that you can get.
There are other ways
that the protein can
interact with itself and
form different structures,
but these are the major two.
Structures are held together
using hydrogen bonds.
And then you can get
tertiary structure.
So there are many different
ways that proteins are
represented in graphical form.
So you can have--
you've seen in our past
lecture with the catalase,
you can have a space-filling
model where all of it's
kind of like the ball
and stick where it just
looks like one giant blob.
And that can give you a
sense of the overall shape
of the protein.
You can also have
line structures
where it's kind of
like the line structure
that you would draw
in organic chemistry
where it shows all
of the different side
chains in the backbone.
And then you have
these ribbon structures
where you can see sort
of the alpha helices
and maybe some beta
sheets over here.
And it shows some
different features
of the structure of a protein.
But the tertiary
structure is how
all of the elements of
the secondary structure
interact to form the overall
shape of the protein.
And it can be formed by
various interactions.
And so, while the secondary
structure is mostly
formed by interactions between
the backbone functional groups,
the, tertiary structure
comes from the interactions
between the side chains.
So you can have these
hydrophobic interactions
if you have alkyl or
aromatic side chains.
So, if your protein
is in a cell,
then it is in a mostly
aqueous environment.
And aqueous
environments are polar.
And so these
nonpolar groups will
tend to coagulate together.
You can have disulfide bonds.
So, if you have the protein side
chains that have sulfur groups,
then they can make covalent
bonds between the sulfurs.
You can have hydrogen bonding.
Again, those
different side chains
have again hydrogens
that are attached
to nitrogens and oxygens
and carbonyl groups
that can form hydrogen bonds.
And then those electrically
charged side chains
can form salt bridges.
So, if you have a
positively charged
and a negatively charged
amino acid near each other,
then they can have an ionic
interaction like that.
Interactions with the
solvent also play a role.
And this is what holds
the protein together
in its functional shape.
And then, lastly, we have
our quaternary structure.
And this is formed
by the interaction
of multiple subunits
coming together
to make a larger protein.
So this is a
picture of catalase.
And you can see each of the
subunits of the catalase
is a different color.
So catalase has four
different subunits.
So these four subunits all
have their own secondary and
tertiary structure.
They're identical.
And then they come together
to make the overall catalase
protein.
Not all proteins have
quaternary structure.
Some just have normal folding
and secondary and tertiary
structure.
And the quaternary structures
are typically held together
by dispersion forces
and hydrogen bonding
between the subunits.
So it's not usually a
covalent interaction,
but it is strong enough to
hold these subunits together
into the correct shape for
the protein to function.
Another key piece
of protein structure
are prosthetic groups.
And these are groups that are
not made out of amino acids.
So they are not peptides,
but they are very
important for protein function.
And some examples are
iron-sulfur clusters.
So these are some
3D representations
of what an iron-sulfur
cluster would
look like where your
iron centers are red,
and the sulfur are
these yellow balls.
So you can have different
numbers of irons and sulfurs
bonded together.
And these play key
roles in photosynthesis
and in metabolism.
So they're really good
at electron transport.
So, in the electron
transport chain
in your cellular metabolism
or in photosynthesis
when you have to transport
electrons in order
to make energy, those
iron-sulfur clusters,
that is where they are
typically found in nature.
And another really
common prosthetic group
is the heme group, which you
may recognize from hemoglobin.
It is used in oxygen
binding and transport.
So it binds to the oxygen and
carries it through your blood.
And it can also be used in
oxygen reactions or oxygen
activation, which is what we're
going to talk about today.
Other types of
prosthetic groups,
you can have lipids
or sugars that
are bound to proteins that
help with protein recognition
and things like that, but
metals and metals centers
are the most common
that are used.
So, if we want to
talk a little bit more
about the heme group is what
we're going to focus on,
the heme group is based off
of this porphyrin structure.
And so this is a porphyrin.
It is made up of
different pyrrole rings
that are bridged together.
And, if you look at
this shape, there's
a nice hole in the center,
which is perfect for inserting
a metal center.
And pyrroles are found--
or porphyrins are found
in many different contexts.
So you can find them in hemes.
Obviously, we've
said that already.
So, if you put an iron
center in the middle of that
and you can add different
functional groups
to the outside of the pyrrole,
then you can make a heme.
In chlorophyll, it
has a magnesium ion
in the center of it.
Enzymes have these
to hold a whole bunch
of different metal centers
or even to not hold any metal
centers, just the very
common organic group.
The organic chemists
said, wow, these enzymes
use all of these
porphyrin groups,
and it does some really
interesting redox chemistry.
So we can make these in the lab.
So they have made synthetic
versions of porphyrins
with manganese,
iron, and cobalt that
catalyze a bunch of
reactions in the lab,
not necessarily in nature.
And they're also found
in petroleum complexed
with vanadium and nickel.
And one of the ways that they're
used in the petroleum industry
is to fingerprint petroleum.
So, by analyzing the
composition of the porphyrin
complexes in the
petroleum, they can detect
the source of oil spills.
They use it in geochemistry and
forensics and things like that.
So now, if we look back
at our heme molecule,
you can see that
all of the hemes
contain this
porphyrin structure.
And then you can add different
groups around the outside,
and that will change
the structure.
And that will
change the function
and change the way
that it is able to bind
to different proteins.
So some of the hemes are just
kind of stuck and held together
with non-covalent interactions.
And some hemes can actually be
covalently bound to proteins,
depending on how they
are functionalized.
And, like we said, they're
good for oxygen binding, oxygen
transport, and
oxygen activation.
And one of the interesting
things that I found
was the role of hemes
in Impossible meat.
So have you guys heard
of the Impossible
meat or the Impossible Burgers,
the Impossible Whopper?
Has anybody tried it?
Yeah?
What are-- is it
actually like meat?
What do we think?
Is it good?
I haven't had it personally.
AUDIENCE: It's pretty good.
SARAH HEWETT: Pretty good.
Mixed reviews?
Not so great?
I haven't actually gotten
the chance to try it,
but an interesting thing,
chemically speaking,
about the Impossible
meat is that, if you're
going to have normal
hamburger from a cow,
then one of the proteins that
is highly abundant in red meat
is myoglobin.
And this is the
structure of myoglobin.
And you can see
that this group here
that is not part of the
peptide arrangement is a heme.
And that happens
to be what gives
red meat a lot of its flavor.
So, when you cook it,
it releases the heme,
and the iron center
provides a lot of flavor.
So what they did was they
found that, in soybean roots,
they have a protein called
leghemoglobin, which
is very similar in
structure to myoglobin
and also contains a heme center.
And so, if they extract this
protein out of the soybean
plant roots, then they can
add it to the Impossible meat.
And then you will have a
plant-based source of heme
that will give you the
meaty, irony flavor that we
have associated with red meat.
So they take proteins from
soybeans and potatoes,
like they make most
vegetarian protein options out
of, and then add this
leghemoglobin from the soybean
roots.
And it is a red color.
So it's also a colorant.
The heme center is what gives
your blood its red color.
So having those conjugated
pi systems in the porphyrin
molecule and combined with
an iron-- or a metal center
will give you colors.
And so it gives it the color
and the flavor of actual meat.
So that's an interesting
role of hemes outside
of your blood or catalase.
Going back to catalase, again,
this is the overall structure.
And it is very hard to
see with these colors,
but there are heme
centers-- you can see them--
in each of the four
subunits of catalase.
And it contains also a
binding site for NADPH.
And this is the
structure of NADPH.
And the NADPH's role is
to maintain the oxidation
state of the iron center.
So it is pretty important
that the iron center maintains
its iron 3 oxidation state.
It goes between iron 3 and
iron 4 while it is active,
but, in order for it
to start the chemistry,
it needs to be iron 3.
And so the NADPH
can donate electrons
to make sure that the iron
is in its active form.
Now, if we want to
take a moment and look
at the actual mechanism for the
reaction of hydrogen peroxide
with catalase, this is a
very pared down version
of the catalase activation site.
So there is a
histidine residue here.
You have your iron
center and your heme.
And then, when hydrogen
peroxide comes in,
the first step is
that those electrons
can remove one of the hydrogens
from the hydrogen peroxide.
And then this oxygen will
bind to your metal center.
So then you have your histidine
now that is protonated.
You have your oxygen bound
to your metal center.
And then this oxygen
can take the hydrogen.
And the iron center can
donate some electrons here
to form water and an
iron-oxygen double bond.
And now this is iron 4.
So iron has donated
some electrons
to this oxygen center,
and it's actually
a radical and a cation.
So that's the first step.
And so that's where our
first hydrogen peroxide
molecule comes in
because, if you remember,
the overall reaction
that we're working with
is two hydrogen peroxides goes
to two waters and one oxygen.
And then the second step
is, once you have this iron
radical cation, there are
two proposed mechanisms
for how this reaction can go.
And it can either
be also mediated
by this histidine residue
where one of the hydrogens
ends up on the histidine.
The other one adds to the oxygen
bound to the metal center.
You release the oxygen, and
this hydrogen comes back in.
And you form your water.
Or you can kind of
ignore this histidine
and do two hydrogen transfers
onto this oxygen bound
to the iron.
And then you make your
water and your oxygen.
And they have done isotopic
labeling studies where
you can make this
first complex and then
add in hydrogen peroxide
that's been labeled
with oxygen-18 isotopes.
And they have found that all
of the oxygen that is produced
is oxygen-18.
So they know that the oxygen
here comes from this peroxide.
And then the oxygen that
is bound to the iron
ends up in the water.
So that's kind of how they
were able to narrow down some
of the mechanisms for this.
And, if you remember,
our reaction,
our decomposition of hydrogen
peroxide can happen on its own.
So here is a mechanism for how
it may happen without catalase.
So you can compare.
One of the proposed
mechanisms is
that the hydrogen
peroxide breaks
into two hydroxy radicals.
Then the second molecule
of hydrogen peroxide
reacts with one of
those hydroxy radicals
to form one molecule of water
and this peroxy radical.
And then you have
one of these and one
of these that are formed.
So those can react and
form your water and then
your molecular oxygen. So
it takes a few more steps.
It's a little bit
slower, but that
is a comparison of how
the enzyme can catalyze
this reaction to
happen much faster
than what may happen in nature.
So that is what is happening in
the decomposition of hydrogen
peroxide, either just
hanging out on the bench top
or with your catalase
catalyzation.
And now we're going to talk
about our goals for day three
and four of catalase.
So, after day one
and day two, you
have seen this reaction happen.
And now, for days
three and four,
we are going to try to
quantify the amount of catalase
in an unknown protein sample.
And then we were going to
quantify the amount of iron
that is present in
our sample of catalase
and try to figure out how
many iron centers there are
per one molecule of catalase.
And, based on the work of
a lot of other scientists,
we know that, theoretically,
it should be how many?
We can go back.
So there are how many
subunits in catalase?
Four.
How many hemes per subunit?
One.
So how many total iron
centers in a catalase protein?
AUDIENCE: Four.
SARAH HEWETT: Four, excellent.
So we know that
there should be four.
And hopefully-- that is
our theoretical value.
Hopefully, you guys are
going to be able to get that
as your answer in the lab.
So how are we going to do that?
First, we're going to talk
about how to quantify proteins.
So it's important to be able to
determine the amount of protein
in a given sample.
In terms of for nutritional
studies, biochemical studies,
you need to know how much
protein that you have.
And there are a couple
of ways that you
can determine the amount
of protein in a sample.
You can do a
nonspecific assay, which
will just tell you how much
overall protein that you have.
It's not specific
to certain proteins.
And some examples of those
are the biuret assay.
You can use UV spectroscopy.
So we did visible spectroscopy
with our phosphate samples
in the Charles River lab.
If you use
ultraviolet light, you
can detect the amount of
protein that you have.
So some of the amino acids have
the aromatic residues or the pi
bonds.
And those will absorb UV light.
So you can quantify
proteins that way.
Or you can do a
Bradford assay, which
is more similar to
the assay that we
did with our phosphate samples
in that it is a visible color
change that you can see and
same with the biuret assay.
And the Bradford assay
is actually the one
that we're going to do in lab.
So we'll talk about
that more in a second.
And, if you want to
know specifically what--
if you want to identify the
amount of one specific protein,
you can do protein-specific
assays such as a Western blood
or an ELISA.
And those use antibodies to
select for specific proteins.
And then you can either
attach a fluorescent tag
to the protein or a
color-changing tag.
So, when the antibody
matches up with your protein,
you get a color change or some
light that you can quantify.
And you can also do protein
mass spectrometry and look at--
you can use that to quantify
the specific proteins also.
So the Bradford
assay is the assay
that we're going to
be doing in the lab.
And the Bradford assay
uses Coomassie dye.
And this is the structure
of Coomassie dye.
And, if you just pour
the Coomassie dye out
of the bottle, it is this
brownish sort of reddish color.
And, when it reacts to
proteins, it turns blue.
So you can quantify
the amount of blue.
And that will tell
you how much protein
you have in your sample.
And the protein reacts with
these sulfonyl groups over here
and causes the color change.
So, when you have all of
these aromatic systems
and electron-rich
groups when you
change the electronic structure
by bonding to a protein,
then you can change the color.
So this is what we
are going to do.
And, in order to quantify
the amount of blue or amount
of protein that we have, similar
to our phosphate analysis
before, we need to make
a series of standards.
So you need to know
what your absorbance is
at different
concentrations of the thing
that you're trying to measure.
So we made our
phosphate standards,
and those also
happened to turn blue.
And we are going to make a
series of protein standards
so that we know what color
our Coomassie dye will
turn a different
protein concentrations.
To do this, we are going to
use bovine serum albumin.
And it's a serum
albumin protein,
which is found in blood.
And bovine means that the one
that we're going to be using
is coming from cows.
And that's helpful because there
is a lot of cow blood left over
from the meat industry.
And it is found in
the blood plasma,
and it maintains-- its
role in a living animal
is to maintain the osmotic
pressure in the blood
and carry biologically important
molecules through your blood
plasma, but we are
going to use it
as a primary standard for
our protein quantification.
And we can do this because it is
abundant, inexpensive, stable,
and reacts well
with Coomassie dye.
So we can get a nice
calibration curve.
And it's also similar
enough to our protein,
catalase, that we can use it
to make our standard curve.
So typically you would try
to use the same molecule
that you are quantifying
to make your standard,
but that's not always possible.
So, in that case,
it's helpful to have
a protein that can kind
of stand in, is abundant,
and easily quantifiable.
So you can buy
different concentrations
of this Bovine Serum
Albumin, or BSA,
from a bunch of different
chemical suppliers.
So you know what the
concentration is, and you
can use that as your standard.
The way that we are going
to do this in the lab
is to prepare standards
very similarly to how
you did for your phosphate.
You will have your
BSA stock solution.
And the BSA that we're going to
be using is in solution form.
And the stock solution is 2,000
micrograms per milliliter.
And you will be
diluting it with buffer.
So again it's really important
to use buffer any time
that you're working
with proteins
because of the
different structures
that we showed you before.
The side chains
could be charged.
And that will impact their
interactions with each other.
So you want to make sure
that the pH is correct
so that your protonation states
of all of your amino acids
are what they should be in terms
of like a physiological pH.
So you'll add-- dilute
your BSA with buffer.
And then you will have a
bunch of different standards
at varying concentrations.
And then you'll have one
where you don't add any BSA,
and it's just the buffer.
And that will serve
as your blank.
The way this is going to work in
lab is that you will pipette--
you'll be using
little microcentrifuge
tubes and the micropipetters.
And so this is a very
quantitative experiment.
So you need to get really
good with your micropipetting
technique and make sure that you
don't contaminate your samples
because you're
going to be working
with very small quantities,
microliters of things.
So you want to
make sure that you
are changing your pipette
tips at an appropriate time
and using the
pipettes accurately.
So you will pipette
the standards
into your microcentrifuge tubes.
And then we will give
you a standard sample--
or an unknown
sample of catalase.
And then you will
put catalase in each
of the microcentrifuge tubes.
And we're going to do five
samples of the catalase
so that we have five
unknowns that you
can do an analysis of
your error on that,
similar to the phosphate where
we ran five standards from--
or five samples from the river.
You guys saw how much
those can fluctuate
depending on how you
prepared the samples
or how well you pipetted.
So it'll be the same thing.
We will have multiples,
multiple trials.
Then you will add
the Coomassie reagent
to each of the standards
and your samples.
And this is where it is going
to be very important that you
pay attention to the
timing of this experiment.
So you will add
your Coomassie dye.
And then you will shake
it up a little bit.
And then, as soon as you add
the dye, you will start a timer.
And you will close the tubes,
shake them, allow the color
to develop for two minutes.
And then, at two minutes, you
will pour all of your samples
into cuvettes.
And, in this case, we will
be using the smaller cuvettes
than what you guys used
for the last samples,
but they go in the
same instrument.
You will transfer your
samples to the cuvettes.
And then you will measure the
absorbance at 595 nanometers.
And the program on
the UV/Vis instruments
are set up to go
to that wavelength
when you click on it.
You need to start running
your samples at 10 minutes.
So this is why it's
really important.
So, once you start
adding the Coomassie dye,
you need to start a timer
because the dye is--
it's important that
all of your samples
incubate for the same amount of
time so that it's consistent.
So you don't want to take
your time like adding it
to the beginning samples so
that, by the time you add it
to your unknowns, it's
been like five minutes.
So you want to work
quickly and carefully.
The dye is most sensitive around
10 minutes after addition.
So that's when you will
get really good spectra.
If you wait too
long, then you will
see that the protein-dye complex
will start to precipitate out
of your solution.
And you'll get these black
chunks in your cuvettes.
And that's when you know that
you can no longer measure
the absorbance of your sample.
So that'll be
careful, and we will
try to stagger people
so that not everybody is
using the UV/Vis at the same
time so that you have your--
you can do everything in
the allotted amount of time.
You will make a
calibration curve,
and it will look
something like this.
And, as you can see, it's
not the most linear thing.
BSA has three
linear regions when
you are doing a Bradford assay.
And the first one is from 0 to
125 micrograms per milliliter.
We don't really have
any data points there,
and your protein concentration
in your catalase sample
should be higher than that.
So we're not really going
to look at that region.
And then the other region
is in the middle here,
either from 125 to 1,000
or 125 to 750 micrograms
per milliliter.
And, when you get your data,
you can look at this and graph
both of these
regions to see which
one gives you a more linear
and more steeper slope.
And that's the one that
you can use to calculate
your unknown samples with.
And the third region is
above 1,000 micrograms
per milliliter,
but, as you can see,
you're getting above one
absorbance unit there.
And so then it's not as
accurate beyond there.
So we're not going
to worry about that.
So, when you get
your data, you'll
need to figure out where
it is most linear, where
the slope is the steepest.
And that is what you
will use to calculate
your unknown concentrations.
And then it is just like
you did for phosphate,
and you'll be able to calculate
your unknown concentrations.
Any questions about
the quantification
of the amount of
catalase protein?
So our calibration curve,
also one thing to note,
is in units of micrograms
per milliliter.
And you'll know how many
milliliters of solution
that you added.
And we know that the
molecular weight of catalase
is 240 kilodaltons or
240,000 grams per mole.
So you can figure out how
many moles of catalase protein
you have from the concentration
and that conversion factor.
So that's something to note.
And then, once we have our
amount of catalase protein,
we can determine the amount
of iron in the protein.
So this is-- and we'll be doing
that using the ferrozine assay.
This is the structure
of ferrozine.
And the ferrozine molecule
by itself is colorless.
And then, when you
complex it with iron,
it turns into a magenta color.
And there are three molecules
of ferrozine for every one iron
ion.
And so it forms in an
octahedral sort of geometry.
So, if there are six
binding sites on iron,
then you'll have one ferrozine
here, one there, and one there.
And it bonds to these two
nitrogen centers here.
And again, like
the Coomassie dye,
there are a lot of pi electrons
and aromatic systems, which
help to give it its color.
So the way that
we're going to do
this is we will be using
again UV/Vis spectroscopy
because we have something that
goes from colorless to colored
when it interacts with
our molecule of interest
or our ion of interest.
So the first step
in this procedure
is going to be adding
methanesulfonic acid.
And then you will heat it at
104 degrees for 40 minutes.
And it's very important that
you keep the temperature range
around 104 degrees.
And you don't want
to go too high
because we'll be heating them
in the microcentrifuge tubes.
And, if you heat it too hot,
then your centrifuge tube
can boil over, or it
can build up pressure,
and the cap will pop off.
And you'll lose all
of your solution.
So you need to be
careful with that.
And the purpose of this
step is to release the iron
from the heme group.
So, when you add a bunch of
acid, the iron gets released.
And then we can
quantify it because it
won't be bound to our heme.
Then we will add
sodium hydroxide
to neutralize the acid.
And then you're going to get a
ferrozine complex mixture that
will be prepared by your TAs.
And you will add it to
all of your samples.
And the mixture
is ascorbic acid,
which reduces the iron 3 to iron
2+ because that is what will
complex with our
ferrozine molecule.
Ammonium acetate helps
to buffer the pH.
Neocuproine binds to any copper
ions that are in the solution.
So the ferrozine ligand is not
necessarily specific to iron.
So, if there are any
copper contaminants,
then it will also
bind to copper,
but the neocuproine is
more specific for copper.
So it will bind
to the copper ions
and make sure that it does
not contaminate your assay.
And then, of course,
the ferrozine,
that binds to the iron to
make the colored complex
that we are going to measure.
And then the-- so the
measurement of the ferrozine
is going to be
pretty much the same
as the BSA and the phosphate.
Similar to UV/Vis,
you'll make a bunch
of standards of iron sulfate.
And then you will have
your catalase samples
that have iron in them.
And then you will make
your standard curve.
The ferrozine is linear.
So you'll be able to make your
standard curve, just graph it,
and use the line.
And then you will be able to
use the equation of your line
to determine your concentration
of your unknown samples
from your catalase.
The data analysis
for this lab is
going to be using the
protein assay results
and the iron assay results.
You will determine the number
of iron centers per catalase.
And so you have the
micrograms per milliliter
of your catalase protein.
So you can convert that
using your molecular weight
to moles of catalase.
And then you will
also get your iron
in micrograms per milliliter.
And, using the molecular
weight of iron,
you can convert that
to moles and then
do a mole-to-mole ratio
of iron to catalase.
And hopefully your answer
is somewhere around four
if all goes well.
So, in your discussion,
you can talk
about sources of
error, how close you
were to the theoretical
value of four,
any discrepancies between
your calculated ratio,
the expected ratio.
And then you'll do an error
analysis of the protein
and iron concentrations.
So you will run
five unknown samples
of catalase and five samples
with the ferrozine assay
of iron.
So you'll have five measurements
that should be the same.
So those you can
do your average,
your standard deviation,
confidence interval.
And then, if you
have any outliers,
that's when you can use the
Q test for the outliers.
And there was a
couple of questions
that came up during the
Charles River lab report.
When we were making
the standard curves
for the phosphate
determination, people
had some outliers in
their standard curves.
And they were
trying to figure out
how they could get rid of
those or if they should.
And the Q test only works if
you're measuring the same thing
multiple times.
So that does not work
for getting outliers out
of a standard linear curve.
But if you have-- in
your standard curve,
if you have one sample
that is supposed
to be a higher
concentration than the one
before it and it has a lower
absorbance or something wildly
higher, then you can look at
it and say I know for a fact
that, if something has
a higher concentration,
it should have a
higher absorbance.
I can get rid of this point.
You can also just kind
of by looking at it--
that's not as
scientific, but you
can make an argument for why you
would remove a data point based
on how it looks compared
to the line of best fit.
And you can also compare the
R squared values of the line
with the point and
without the data point.
And, if it gets closer
to 1 when you remove it,
then it is more linear.
You obviously don't want to
be taking out data points left
and right until you only
have like your three best
points that give you
a super straight line.
But, if there are any that are
very obviously not on the line,
then that is one way
that you can remove them.
So yeah, are there any
questions about catalase
or any of the other labs?
Anything?
This is all I have for today.
This was kind of a short one.
No.
All right, then those of
you who are going to lab,
you can head up there.
And don't forget to
turn your reports in.
And yeah, the
clipboard is around.